okay chair you're now live
thank you uh welcome
members out of the torridge council
independent members and the public
to this meeting of the torridge harbour
board bitterford harbour board
we hope it'll be a relatively short
meeting and we hope you'll enjoy it
um item apologies for absence
thank you chair i haven't received any
apologies for today's meeting
and how are we doing for membership
it's just councillor mcgoff missing now
chair
so we've got councillors christy james
and rossi president
right yes proper job silver cora
yeah right item two
the minutes of the harbor board meeting
of the 10th of december
i'll go through them looking for errors
first
beginning using page numbers at the
bottom
page 3 page four
page five page six
page seven i have something
yes um i don't understand item 55
this the middle paragraph there doesn't
seem to make sense
i know what it's trying to mean but
there's some rather strange words there
what exactly is
have any ideas how it could be tidied up
made more
accurate
i probably can't help i'm not quite sure
what it was trying to say
i think it chair i can help um i think
it's supposed to say that
um some vessels that are now out of a
bank house were brought over from
brunswick
they did have owners but unfortunately
the owners have
since disappeared and have been unable
to trace them
how many were referring to
hello i didn't hear that
uh probably about less than half a dozen
chair
right um
the word i don't like is timely timely i
thought meant
fairly swift whereas this is going to be
time consuming
yeah data
i'd like to change timely to time
consuming then i can
follow the logic of it
right so we're happy then that they'd be
recorded as a true and correct record
i'll have to put it to the vote i'm
afraid
let me have a proposal on secondary
please i'll propose from the chair
i'll second thank you council james
thank you chair councillor christie oh
mr gibbs paul mr hardaka
he's having some technical issues
kirstie's who might not be able to vote
okay shall i move on yes please
councillor hicks
for councillor mcgough
not present thank you councillor james
or councillor rossi
paul thank you that's unanimous chair
proper job anybody wishing to comment on
those minutes now
just just one thing um chair uh just
verify that the process to remove those
votes is going ahead is it
now i haven't started the process as uh
as yet it's a i'd have to serve notice
on them and then wait up to 12 weeks and
then we could take action but it's not
something i've started yet
okay it will be started very soon will
it
yeah i can do that i can prioritize that
chair no problem
can i say something please john paddy
yes
yeah um i just wondering which boats
you're referring to because i thought
quite a few of the boats at the
bank end where the skate park used to be
are actually
there legally
there's a number of boats there liver
boards that pay rent to torres district
council
and then right at the very far end
there's a group of about
four or five boats that were abandoned
by their owners when we cleared um
brunswick wharf around about two years
ago so
in the process of clearing brunswick
wharf a very small collection of boats
were brought over
to bank end and where they've since been
abandoned by their owners
um we did initially have some um
conversations with the owners in the
very early days but they've
none of them none of the boats there are
worth of any value
and hence they've been abandoned
thank you okay
uh right we move on now to
item three action list
how are things moving how are things
going
i'll take the minute number eight
yeah chad do you want me to answer that
yes please
so item number eight um paul and i have
been in discussions and had a meeting
with a local company just looking at
progressing potentially or doing at
least a business model
a business case to see if it's worth
exploring any further which will come
back to
this committee to give you
uh detailed information before we make
any decision
um number 37 yeah item number 37
chair as you know i think
you'd like to come in on minute eight
yeah i just got just a quick question uh
what
what company are you in discussions with
initially it was a discussion with um
evans transport
who are the stevedores which leads then
on to 37
of which myself potentially the harbour
master and the chair of this committee
we've got to meet up with nigel evans
arranged for the 26th to see how we can
because they've taken over
uh well they're the stevedore anyway but
they've taken over dealing with the clay
transport
from sobelco so it's just trying to
you know brainstorm really and look at
other ideas how we can
get extra business into the harbour
okay um i have one other one another
question or
maybe a suggestion um do we have do we
have a crane driver a new crane driver
now um yes all right let me dance the
chair
yes please okay so paul will go into
more details
but we've just had a ship come in uh
which paul totally dealt with
um and we had a crane driver that was um
supplied by evans transport
um who operated the crane he's trained
he's got the right
certificates um and a new style of
loading was used where they took either
end of the crane so the crane was in the
middle
seemed to work very very well i think
paul will go into more detail was very
pleased with how he
conducted himself um
and we now have a break unfortunately
it'd be nice to know if we had another
vote in next week for us to decide what
we're going to be doing
in the longer term whether we continue
to use this
this gentleman who seems very capable
but it's all the other
little jobs that we need to maintain on
the harbour such as when there are boat
lifts in and out
the weekly crane maintenance
so it's it's how we deal with those paul
and i have been putting our heads
together and we have a
a plan how that will work um but by the
time we have our next harbour board
meeting
um we'll have something confirmed for
you
so we are covered in that aspect
thank you when you confirm it that will
be with costings will it
yes yes chair everything's yeah
obviously done with costings
um it's obviously to to ensure that we
are viable when when we have a ship in
thank you right
now we've got um 64
does that answer your question
councillor christie
yes it does thank you very much proper
job
now it's new one i believe to item
four which is public contributions
to my knowledge we have none is that
correct
richard
item five is agreement of the agenda
between part one and two and there's no
part two items so we can move on
item six urgent matters i have none
unless there's something arisen today
so we move on to item seven
financial summary page nine
thank you chair it'll be that'll be me
again
um you've got the summary in front of
you
um i'll just go through a few points and
hopefully answer any questions
if i can't i'll get back to you so
as you get split into two parts first
part being harbor and then the second
are being the pilotage we we've always
separated those two out but it's all
part of the
heart room facility so as you look the
first line
with with employees um the only variants
over there
was previously with michael when even
when we haven't had a crane there is a
element of work that needs to be done on
the key side maintaining the crane
weekly checks
for insurance purposes when we look at
premises
um the additional 1000 there is for
the security protocols that we've put in
to ensure that the harvest safe when
we're operating
throughout the year transport
is over by three but that's there's
additional repairs that we had to have
done to the crane
um and mileage and transport
relating to that for the company um
the supplies and services 1003
that's that's accommodation and
substance um for the staff in the
harbour
minimal hundred pound so if you look at
customer receipts you know we are
down but we were expecting another ship
um and that has happened we were
expecting another ship
in the early part of march which will go
into the final
quarter um so the harbor income itself
was looking at down five grand on
projected budget
but that ship has now come in which paul
will deal with in a moment
and then we go on to the the pilotage
and while saving on employees that's
because our relief
staff there's always a budget for our
relief staff and while
unfortunately they're not being used
there's an underspend there
because there's low ships um
transport once again there's an
underspend
employee so you know the budgets
don't look great on paper when they look
at this but this is you know what we can
only do
from uh you know budgeting process in
november for the fourth coming year
so any questions really chair or any
other members
right let's try it open the members
[Music]
all very quiet
i think you chair from i think obviously
for the next half of a meeting
we will have a full year's work in
summary of our finances and that will
give us a better picture
and i'm sure there'll be more questions
then
okay well we'll move on to agenda item
eight which is the
port marine safety code annual report
something that has to be done
thank you um so
presenting to members support me in
safety code
annual report um written report by
myself
and there'll be a verbal um
um report given by our designated person
janet williams um so this report is part
of our
our portland safety code compliance um
and you'll see this report every year
around this time brought to the harbour
board um
it's been a large volume of work um and
it's involved
reviewing of our safety management
system um
reviewing of our risk assessments
and the creation of the marine safety
plan taking our marine safety plan from
2019
to 2021 to 2021 to 23.
now i haven't included all of that
paperwork
um with this report because it's it's
very very weighty
and really that's the job that you're
asking the designated person to do
so that you're asking janet williams as
designated
person to have overview of all of that
work and she'll be reporting to you
um later on in this report um it's all
pretty much
set out in the report for members um i'm
happy to take questions at this time or
um or we could bring in janet and and um
and and and get a and get a verbal
update from janet
it's over to you sir we'll move right on
to janet thank you
thank you chair thank you paul good
afternoon everybody
um i've been asked to provide some input
to the board
um on the recent audit and the ongoing
review of the harbour safety management
system and most importantly to advise
the board
on the compliance with the port marine
safety code
and as paul says i'm doing that in my
capacity as designated person for the
harbour
and so it's my role to provide
independent insurance
assurance um on the harbour safety
management system
so the review of the um of the process
kicked off with
um i think was a three-day audit and
covering all the relevant
hardware operations so that's um
pilotage
surveys and operations on the key side
and moorings emergency incidents
and so quite a range and was was
included
and following the audit i provided a
number of recommendations which have
been
uh since work through by paul and his
team
and i think at this stage i would like
to thank paul
and richard and all of the harbour staff
and for their work and cooperation
um in the process and i think we've
established
an excellent level of communication on
all of this and
i've been given access to the full range
of of
harper documentation and i've been
copied in on on emails
um on both uh progress with items coming
out of the audit
um as well as the uh some of the
day-to-day
uh running um of the harbour you know
harbor master directions and things like
that so that's
something really positive that i'd like
the um the ball to be aware of
and so i'm sure that members of the
board are
aware that um the port marine safety
code
and the um the associated guidance the
good practice
on and port marine organ operations
these are both very weighty documents um
and they're applicable to
all sizes of um harbor operations
and this does give rise to some
challenges um
especially for a small and occasional
port like biddeford
and so a lot of our discussions and
throughout the process has been around
and how we meet our legal obligations in
a way that's
that's commensurate with the size of
operations here
but throughout those discussions we've
always looked to ensure that the core
safety requirements
um are not compromised and i think
that's that's the key to my review
and of the safety management system and
my and my recommendation to the to the
board
so paul's outlined in his report um
the main measures that need to be
considered under the code so i don't
need to cover that
and but i would like to acknowledge um
some of the the main areas of work
that have been progressed as a result of
the audit and so for me
um the the key aspect has been the
review um and update of the risk
assessments for a wide range of hardware
operations
um including a call-in um of risk
assessments from third parties such as
uh as evans and um operations around the
the oldenburg
um and these are really the the basis
for understanding
and mitigating all the risks in in those
areas
and so that's that's been the the key
part of the work that that paul's
progressed and there's also been the
review of the
duties and powers of the harbor
authority and i'm pleased that the issue
around the
the duty holder has been clarified by
the board that's really useful
and there's also been a review of the
rules and responsibilities of all the
harbour staff
and i've also been included in as i say
in harbormaster
instructions and directions so i've i've
confirmed that those communication
channels are in place so that's that's
another very positive thing
um i'd also say as well that while this
isn't visible to the board
um all of the information held in
relation to the harbour
has been made available for me to access
and review
at any time and how we hold and manage
that information
um is much improved and is a real
helpful audit process
for the audit process and process
purposes
so given the amount of work that's been
done
there are some areas that been carried
into this year's work plan
and i've confirmed that those are in
place and i would like to highlight that
there are a couple of areas that have
been beyond the
control of the harbour team and as
you'll be aware
we're currently uh updating our website
platform
so we're all caught up in that and the
web team have the content ready to go
but we're just waiting the new website
and that's going to be a key aspect of
communications and transparency going
forward
and we're also at the behest of the
department of transport
in relation to updating our harbour
directions as well and so the delay with
that is not is with them at the moment
so that that's beyond our control
but again that's something that's been
carried forward but these
aren't core safety issues and so i'm
comfortable for them to be taken forward
into into next year's work plan
um i would have to advise the the board
that it's the nature of any safety
management system
that it's never actually considered
complete and done
and it needs to be kept under review
and updated um as part of the process of
of continual improvement and and i think
we've got that
approach in place and the process is in
place to support that
so to summarize chair and i'm happy to
advise the board that in my opinion
that we're meeting the requirements of
the port marine safety code and this can
be reported to the
maritime coast guard agency and thank
you and i'm happy to take any questions
right tim how much of the
documentation relation relating to the
port marine safety code will be
available online
um chair uh i can answer that
it's um it's a discussion i had in the
last couple of days with
the designated person janet williams and
probably all a very large amount
but the discussion i had with janet um
was that we would go back to the guide
to good governance
and see what government is recommending
so
a significant chunk certainly uh the
marine safety plan
the safety management system in itself
part of directions
a very very lar a large body of work is
to go on to the website but we are we're
gonna go we'll we'll go and seek
um advice from from the department for
transport as to what they want
us to put up on put to put up onto the
website when it's
um up and running okay thank you paul
anybody anyone else wishing to speak
yeah john paddy oh sean only go uh john
brother yep okay i just wanted to know
does the port marine safety code
extend to the uh land of israel walk
area
importantly safety code covers uh the
the harbor authority so
where yes it does yeah and that was
included in the audit we did we did them
take a look down there didn't we paul
and there was some works that were that
were done um
a long landing video as a result of the
of the audit so yeah my understanding
was that that was included as part of
the um
as part of the review okay my concern
is that the access to vessels which
means climbing over railings
and and who's responsible
you know without you know without
sitting here and having a big discussion
about
it john i certainly think if you've got
concerns about that
that's something we could probably talk
outside of this meeting i do
think if you know and you you brought up
a number of points about the
moorings and facilities policy at the
last meeting
i do think this is starting to show more
and more
certainly to my mind and i and i hope to
councillors mine
that what's needed for the harbour is a
is a
harbor liaison forum and or a harbour
user group where
these these kind of um
technical in-depth conversations can be
had at the meeting
prior prior to this committee meeting
but
um if you want to drop me an email john
happy to pick a pick up on that
um and then progress that further
um but yes um and
i am aware that the fresh springs has
taken a great deal of effort to um
have a safe access but um yeah if you if
you want to drop me an email on that one
then it's something that uh
an email to myself and janet the
designated person that's
that's why she's at this meeting today
and and that's what she's been
bringing to the port um we're happy to
take that forward
drop me an email sir
anyone else wishing to speak on this
no does it require a formal resolution i
note that
um we're supposed to write to the
maritime and coast guard agency
advising them that it's compliant does
that need a resolution
um it might make it more formal
mr chair the way i thought was that it
would also
go from here to the community and
resources
as the duty holder so you you could
you you could it could be noted and then
if you felt
it could be noted at this uh meeting and
then at the cnr
meeting you could make a resolution that
um that the
the commit the duty holder was minded
that the chairman writes to the mca so
however tom would think it would be
appropriate sir
um it's probably best that stacy advised
but
it won't harm taking a vote on it now to
be honest
okay all right can i recommend that um
hoverboard approve this and with the
recommendation that it goes to cnr
yeah we're taking a vote that we approve
it not adopt it
your recommendation to see if there's no
amendment suggested your recommendation
is that it goes to cnr
um for adopting
fair enough so i'll move that we do that
that we
adopt it and put it to cnr
with a recommendation
okay is there a second if it needs
thank you can we put it to the vote
please
yes thank you chair councillor christie
oh
mr gibbs or
mr hardacre
still having technical issues thanks
councillor hicks
or has cancer mcgoff joined
no he hasn't thank you
councillor james or
councillor rossi four
thank you that's unanimous chair thank
you
so now we move on to item nine
harbor masters quarterly report
so that's over to you paul i guess
thank you chair a very brief report um
we haven't had a great deal of
commercial traffic in um
um in biddeford harbour obviously we've
been in the middle of a
parabolic pandemic and um
so there's been very little very little
movement um
and i've i've been doing considerable
amount of work from working from home
and
attending the harbour as and when
required um
uh we we we recently had a ship
um over the weekend as you're aware we
had the sad death of our claim driver
mike pryor
in january and um and as richard haste
was pointed out we do we do
we do have a new a new crane driver uh
provided by evans
um on the yellow end um
uh we were jewish sound campaign in in
the next
couple of weeks so every six months we
we get a campaign of sam so that that
should be taking place
um in in the next couple weeks
on on a positive note in in terms of
pilotage the um
the shipyard um at appledore has now
reinstated its um
uh slipway the patent slipway now is
fully operational
and we brought our first barge up there
from kanemore list
a couple of weeks ago that's her kind of
had a complete refit in appledore
and she went away to see uh a couple of
couple of evenings ago
so we're hopeful to be picking up more
work from the shipyard and on the
shipyard the gates there should
be fully operational so i'm not a great
deal really to report from
um this report um
i'm happy to take questions from members
the only recommendation that i've put
in this report and it's something i
thought i'd
do it separately uh to the port marine
safety code annual report and that's the
creation of a
harvard liaison forum now in the action
minutes um at the beginning of this
report there was something in there
about the harvard user group and
trying to um engage with the harbour
user group well
the management team of torres district
council we've not met with the harvard
user group
now for well over two years
and coming out of this audit and some
what we've picked up is and particularly
from dealing with the department for
transport about
harvard directions and
changing of bylaws the department for
transport
and the port marine safety code are both
very very keen
that the harbour authority has a
mechanism whereby it's able to
demonstrate
well it's a mechanism where it can
consult with its key stakeholders and
and actually i've got a list of our key
stakeholders and
it's quite significant when when you run
down it there are more
more people than you would think that
stakeholders of the poor
and it's the government's view that we
have a mechanism that could facilitate
that now
not only for good governance of the port
but also
um in order for us to get more um
bylaw making powers we need to show in
the next two or three years to the
department for transport that we've
fully consulted nothing
to just give you an example um we had at
the last meeting
john puddy raised a lot of issues about
the
morrison facilities policy and obviously
during this pandemic
that moorings facilities policy has
found its way
through the various committee stages and
come out the other side now
if we had a harbor liaison forum
john would be able to bring these issues
to that forum which would meet
and talking to the designated person
we're talking about
once or twice a year two or three weeks
before the harbour board met
it would be um we we would um send out
the agendas from the
committee if they were in agreement with
that we'd
we'd take the minutes and the minutes
would then come up to the harbour board
for noting or discussion
and it's a very tried and tested formula
and it would certainly
um resolve the issue that we had i i
thought it was an issue
last week where john was trying to
consult and
i don't feel the harbour board's really
such a good vehicle for that but i put
it in
i'll put it in as a recommendation for
this report that the members give
consideration to myself and and
and management um colleagues forming
this harbor liaison form and i've had a
lot of discussions with richard haste
about it and
obviously i wouldn't be able to do it if
richard wasn't
um in agreement with this and would help
me with this and also i've had
discussions with
the designated person but not not with
tom vanstrom today so
it's something that i put in the
recommendations if members would give
consideration
we could set that up on your behalf um
we're happy to take questions on
anything else that members have picked
up on on on this report thank you
tim first of all yeah i picked up from
the accounts that we're paying
an extra thousand pounds a year for
security on the key
during loading operations was that
correct
yes that's correct yeah well we aren't
getting very good value for money i can
tell you
last friday um
the so-called security guy on the
entrance was half asleep and a car drove
in and weaved its way through mr ways
and mr
um evans lorries so i thought
that was about two o'clock last last
friday afternoon
oh sure okay we'll look into that
when ships are loading or unloading i
i spend possibly most of the time on the
side
on the location micromanaging it i
missed that
but it is the re we have look at the we
have looked at the risks
and the difficulties we've got him is
it's a car park
95 of the year and five percent of the
year
we turn it on but surely it's a simple
thing
to just push the uh the barrier gate
across in and out when when the lorries
are going in and out
that wasn't there well obviously the
security guard in that instance wasn't
doing his job
the last couple days i have had a
discussion with richard haste
about not having ped security
and putting in torrance district council
stuff so that
you know that is something we are
considering but uh yeah i
i um i hear what you're saying and uh
we'll
we'll certainly investigate sir yeah
it was a really hairy thing it was a
woman driving she had to weave away
through
through the through the arctic trucks
um chair mr mr gibbs if you see that or
any member of the public then
please contact us at the time so we can
deal with it
to prevent it happening on a regular
occurrence so if that happens again
which i hope it doesn't then i need to
know straight away
code of curiosity do you have any
sanctions against that lady what could
you have done about it
she drove out the other side yeah but uh
mr chair um
you know this whole meeting is being
dominated by the property safety code
and rightly so
um and as you're aware over the last
number of months
we've been actively looking at bylaws
and or harbor directions harbour
directions would be
ideal for the port because in the
harbour directions you would
you would see a whole group of
directions specifically directing
vehicles and how vehicles are to be
managed on the key but
um sorry but currently um
um we don't have any by the bylaws we've
got are 1896
and they didn't have cars back in 1896
so
hence why we were actively looking at
having improved bylaws and all
directions going forward
chair ultimately you ask
sanctions it's not about the sanctions
for that individual person
it is like paul has just said about the
safety of anybody entering
basically a dangerous operating area so
if the security weren't doing their job
we'll look into
it i'll see if i've got any cctv footage
um
and we'll prevent it from happening
again
um so the main reason for security
is for health and safety purposes as
you know our safe systems at work
but thank you for raising it mr gibbs
yeah
right uh anyone else with comments
please john paddy right yes
yeah i just want to compliment paul on
the um what he was just saying about
having a
um consultation with harbor users i
think that's a really great
way forward because what we what we
really don't want
we don't want to learn negative
approaches
due to a lack of communication so i
think actually
cooperating in a positive manner is a
really great way forward
because the fact is there are quite a
few users in the harbour
and everyone wants to get
bitter food to become a great place i
mean i'm talking from the perspective of
tourism
incoming so i think anything we can do
to enhance the experience of people
both permanent birth holders and
temporary birth holders is well worth
the effort so thank you very much paul
for that initiative
the the only reservation i would have is
that it
doesn't just become a talking shop
how do you deal with that
well sorry if i could answer that on
your um on behalf of the harvard
authority
i am um not that long ago i was the
chairman of southwest regional ports
association
i've been chairing for many many years
um
councillor hicks and um and richard
haste is also very
experienced officer and it's about the
same as what you're doing at the moment
chair it's about meeting management and
managing your meetings and keeping
things brief and
sticking to the point and uh yeah i
understand what you're saying and now
you know a good chairman is someone who
keeps the meetings ticking along and we
don't we don't we don't get bogged down
on the
people bringing the same agenda items
you know months on months back to the
meetings and as you say
degenerating into a talking shop so
there is a
um i have got experience of chairing
meetings and then
you know look to him your your lead on
it
yeah was someone else wanting to speak
there
no right
one one thing that sort of runs in my
mind i go back about
more than 10 years now and we suddenly
had a call members of the harbour board
and we went on board some dredger type
thing
on biddeford key and went out with the
pilot where he met a boat off the bar he
jumped on
or you know he went in his pilot's boat
and jumped up onto that boat
and we followed him in and it actually
taught me an awful lot about what the
pilots do
what the harbor is about the problems of
working
harder now i've had the benefit of
seeing that
very few members currently on the
council would have
in two years time we have an election
we'll have a new council
and i would like to think that within
the next two years
when a boat comes in during the day
when it can be arranged that members of
the harbour board
and basically biddeford
members are invited to
do that trip so they can really see
what is involved i don't know what
what counselor christie thinks of it
yeah i quite enjoy that i'm not sure how
i missed the last trip actually i don't
recall there being one but
i've been on the harbour ball sometime
but yes i i'd enjoy that
chair i can i can certainly arrange that
um i can certainly arrange that for
members going forward it's um
it's something that can be relatively
easily arranged doesn't when
required one accepts it'll be at short
notice when a boat's coming in
but i just feel it would be helpful to
counselors generally
and the long you know future of the
harbor board
yeah well depending on the type of
trend could i just say depending on the
time scale i would quite enjoy doing
that but obviously i've got
a 45-50 minute journey to get to
biddeford
so that would have to be took into
account
yeah tell me paul you generally get a
couple of days warning of these votes
coming in don't you
uh chair i'm you normally i get a
a couple of weeks um yeah
normally it's a week 10 days but last
week it was literally a couple of days
but
in the grand scheme of things we on we
normally
a couple of weeks we can start penciling
pencilling dates in sir
it would be very good at midnight it
will need to be a daytime job
yeah nice sunny day
i think if you all really want to learn
something it's probably best to go at
midnight
and then you realize just the real true
nature of the pilot's job
i think one can imagine it during the
daytime
um right anyone else with questions on
this harbour masters quarterly report
how many fishing boats are running out
of apple door and biddeford at the
moment
um currently chair um
we had a couple of vessels running out
of biddeford
the um the lucy ii which has just been
sold
belong to the officially family uh
relentless
um which um belongs to the fishy family
in appledore um we've got um
um serene sky and uh
also a couple of other smaller smaller
netting and um and trawling vessels
so literally a handful but um appledore
fishkey itself which is
um managed by torres district owned by
torres district council of which i've
got some management responsibilities um
it's thriving at the moment um we
support clavelli
we support padstow or ilfacoom
uh we support a number of other
artisanal beaches
in in the north of devon and um
the the actual fish key where we do a
lot of processing and packing of fish is
doing very well at the moment and on top
of that
we've just uh opened well torrey
district council has granted a license
to a fishmonger to open on the site
there
and that's doing very very well in apple
door on the fish key
selling a lot of fish and also as well
as that
we land significant i mean quite
significant amounts of lobster
significant amounts of crab and spider
crab and also in the last
six months we've we've created a
um mussel purification plant on the side
site
appledore fish stock and the mussels
from the river torrids are now being
purified on the site and
the person concerned with that is
currently unable to keep up with demand
through the fishmonger so um
the fish keys got full occupancy and
very supportive of our local fishing
industry chair
good councillor james yeah
could i just briefly in the last two
meetings over the last
month that we've had with uh sir jeffrey
cox our
mp he's been quite keen
on the torridge of doing things to um
use the court more and encourage more
and he's convinced that we will get more
fishing
votes coming out so a sort of resume of
what we are doing what paul's just
talked about
would be very handy for my next meeting
with him
um just to show that we are doing stuff
we are
moving forward if that's possible paul
yeah i can do that councillor james and
they're also last week
we we put out a press release through
harry roper
and had quite a lot of detail on the
apple door fish key i can get harry to
send that over to you and i'll
i'll put together a little resume and
then and email it over to you sir
all right thank you very much thank you
yeah i can confirm that i was quoted on
it
um anyone else wishing to speak
well we've gone through the meeting
quicker than i expected we have to note
that report we don't have to take it to
the vote
i'm going to take a chance to say any
other business
yeah the only other thing i was going to
point out about that report was
the recommendation as to myself and um
richard haste and other management
colleagues forming a harvard liaison
forum
um i'm just looking for a strategic
steer on that sir
okay we'll go with that no no councillor
christie wishes to speak in a moment
yes can i just raise one thing um i've
got to be a bit careful what i say here
because
i sit on torridge's planning committee
and we have the application for
brunswick wharf
coming up very soon and uh as part of
the application
it shows a pontoon going out into the
river
it's very difficult to get any
measurements from it i reckon it must be
a hundred foot at least
um and i noticed that there's no uh
consultation with our harbour master
um i'm sure it will be raised at
planning um can i just ask
paul what are your views on a pontoon
coming out into the river
um well i suppose in a way it
goes back to this i think
you know colleague you know seeking
strategic direction from you guys for a
harvard liaison forum because i'm not
being consulted on it
and it's the sort of business that we
would take to the harbour liaison forum
kick it around the liaison for and have
a get a discussion
and then we would bring that up to the
harbour board in the minute so
i haven't been consulted on it um my
only
i'm sure it'll be fine but my only view
is that um
they would probably i'd have to i'd have
to go and consult with stacy but i
suspect that one
they'll need the harbour board's
permission for this
and certainly we want to be able to
demonstrate we've consulted with
stakeholders and two i i
i think thinking aloud that they'll need
that marine management organization
license to put it
on to now but certainly um
need to seek permission from you guys
from the from the members of this board
yeah thank you the only reason i'm
asking is um it is part of the planning
application
and uh if that planning application is
passed then there is a presumption that
you can go ahead with it
um this is what worries me slightly that
if there's been no consultation with the
harbour board
and yet it is part of the planning
application i'm not quite certain where
that leads us
i would suggest that he carries planning
consent but he doesn't have the consent
in effect of the landowner to do it
councillor christie so he couldn't do it
without the harbor board's consent would
be my guess
is stacy there is she any comment
yes chair i am um there is a reason um
for the pontoon
um i can't remember at the moment it's
an asian redwood thing
it's something to do with the
environment agency i believe but i can't
give a
more specific answer at the moment i
think the best thing that i can do
is ask adrian redwood to drop you a line
because
it wasn't in the original plans there is
a reason for it now but
i can't specifically recall
in fact i'll email him now when when
we're talking see if i can get a
response
but do you agree with my interpretation
even if he's got planning it doesn't
mean they can put it there
um well
torridge under the contract torridge
would have
to confirm that we're satisfied with the
development as a whole
so i suspect it will come within that
so you've got two heads here one is the
planning department one is the landowner
um under the the contract um
if they get a satisfactory plan uh
permission
um then they're able to go ahead so if
there is a pontoon within that
and tommy just satisfied as landowners
then it will go ahead
so it's a cnr thing really councillor
hicks yeah but if the harbour board
weren't happy with it
then harbourboard would have to make a
recommendation to cnr
but cnr have already approved the
conditional sale contract
um i mean just one i mean obviously
chair what you don't want is a pontoon
that sticks out into the harbour that
makes it impossible for us to swing
um ships on the birth and turn them
around on the tide so i mean that's just
one
obvious issue when you start talking
about 100 foot pontoons but i mean
i'm sure there's lots of others if i put
my mind to it
i would suggest that the officers need
to do some talking in the very near
future
councillor rossi yeah i think the
question would be who would
who would own the pontoon would it be um
leased out by the by simon friend or
would it
revert back to the council for us to
do with what we wanted or and who would
be responsible for dredging the births
around the
pontoon if it was for boats
is it just for um pedestrians just to
walk out onto the river or is it
you know before and obviously it's
taking up space on the
brunswick wolf key itself um which would
be
better allocated for um moorings and
bursts for other vessels that we would
get
generating income from so
can you answer that
those um those conditions haven't been
um set out yet um i think the original
it was anticipated that the pontoon
would come to torridge um
torridge don't want to be liable for
maintaining that
um there's also discussion as to whether
it will be public or private
um you know i think the difficulty from
torridge's perspective is the mores that
the more that is there and the more that
is handed over storage and we're going
to have to maintain
um and it's a maintenance liability that
i don't think tommy's want going forward
correct yes i totally agree with you and
i think we should just have
the key itself and not upon two and at
least we can maintain the key
um a lot a lot more cheaply and then the
bursts on the along the key would be
a lot easier easily maintained than a
pontoon
uh mr gibbs i'm not quite sure what use
it will be because
the water's so shallow there are you
about half the tides
nothing be able to float there exactly
would have to be dredged
if you wanted well there's a whole new
ballgame yeah yeah exactly
so it would cost a lot of money to
maintain it as a pontoon
for bursts for boats yeah
somebody needs to do a lot more homework
i think
right we go back to this question of how
do we feel about the setting up of a
liaison
group
yeah nothing is a good idea
yeah i'm happy to support it
if that's paul and richard phil would be
advantageous thank you
do we need a formal resolution to that
fact
i would suggest chair that we note
uh the first part of the the
recommendation
and add that we approve
um this creation of a hard board liaison
yeah i was just thinking if we take a
vote then it's probably recorded
yeah well i think we should do a vote
yeah
well so just know the first part of the
report and
uh take a vote on the recommendation to
um because there's sentences there
really create a harbor liaison form
in order to support
you proposing that can i yeah i'll
propose it i'll i'll second it
thanks joe right let's put it to the
vote
thank you chair councillor christie oh
mr gibbs for mr hardacre
he's left the meeting no thank you
councillor hicks or councillor james
or councillor rossi definitely for
thank you that's unanimous chair
right i don't think there's anything
else to come
uh just one thing sorry chair just one
one thing
um i've had a few uh emails messages
um from and peter's probably had these
as well
possibly from um
let me just check i can't remember his
name martin leslie harlan
the owner of the pacemaker um and it's
quite abusive messages and the usual
stuff he used to send before
um are wondering if we could send him a
letter or do something about this
to stop the abuse
it's been going on for some time yeah
stacy
chair probably not a discussion for a
public meeting i'm happy to have a
a chat um with members and i can't talk
about individuals in a part one meeting
i'm happy to end the meeting or have a
part
um or go into a part two discussion
um i think we probably do need to go
into part two don't we
very quickly yes i'll propose it
i'll second it
take a vote thank you chair councillor
christie
mr gibbs or
councillor hicks or
councillor james or
councillor rossi thank you this
unanimous chair
thank you that means i've got to say to
members of the public i'm sorry
but we have to leave you at this stage
because we're clearly going to be
discussing
individuals
and that has to be done privately
unfortunately so i thank you for your
attendance
and we say cheerio for now